[Music]
all you do is take breasts out is he
seriously trying to convince this
mystical Chinese artifact store to stock
his bathroom travel caddy look I've
gotta have him it's a present for my son
for Christmas it's exactly what I've
been looking for and I've been
everywhere you've been looking for a
furry singing tiny creature and you
looked everywhere else first before the
mystical Chinese artifact store what
responsibility and with great
responsibility comes great dammit
mobilize have almost the same rules
denounced cool forget no matter how much
he cries no matter how much he begs
if only the kid had also included the
consequences of ignoring the rules along
with the rules themselves
looks more like Hill Valley to me steven
spielberg presents christmas main
character opens the engine compartment
of their broken-down car only to have
smoke pour out in their face cliche Hey
look they're still playing ET in Close
Encounters of the Third Kind at this
theater what kind of a sick optometrist
uses optical illusion font on their main
sign he's just in with blind people here
really Burger King next to an Animal
Clinic see this is how rumors get
started
phoebe cates isn't moving in stereo in
this scene I realize this guy's a
goofball but how does an adult person
forget to cross the T in their own
signature and I have the same purpose in
life
what movie am i watching for a minute
there it was it's a Wonderful Life now
it's The Wizard of Oz this morning look
if he's a doofus enough to leave his
nameplate in the holder upside down the
previous night when did he have the time
or inclination to turn it right-side up
why does this bar serve beer by pouring
the bottle into a giant glass coffee mug
that's two times too big Judge Reinhold
rules in the 80s consisted of
fantasizing about Phoebe Cates and
enabling Axel Foley is illegal Beverly
Hills investigations holy Sh now I'm
literally watching It's a Wonderful Life
you said it won't wait till Christmas so
we better open it now but it was fine
being in this container and inside
wrapping paper for however long it took
you to drive from New York City to
Kingston balls keep them away from water
don't give them any water to drink and
whatever you do don't give him a bath
what happens if this asshole gets a
bunch of ketchup and mustard on him do
you just let him keep the stains what if
he licks the ketchup and mustard after
midnight is that feeding him
wait a second he just hit a key that
should have produced a higher tone but a
lower tone is what we heard geez how
much juice is in that work seriously
this gets dad made him drag a whole tree
to the Peltzer residence while dressed
as a tree using no vehicles or carts of
any kind whoa whoa gizmo don't do that
in Billy's room corey feldman is
addictive gizmos the fact that I don't
have one of these tiny Donkey Kong
arcade games to play with right now
they might even replace the dog as the
family pet dog senses its being insulted
cliche how did these assholes do this I
mean yeah when they turn into gremlins
later that would make more sense but
while they're still in their cuteness
stage and really small and Barney didn't
make a peep when five little evil mogul
eyes picked him up and took him down the
stairs and started stringing Christmas
lights around him nobody cares hate
Christmas it really makes you feel like
you're ours well Thanksgiving doesn't
have presents so mr. Hanson is one of
those middle school teachers who love to
work late at night on school property
conducting experiments on rare species
since when does this ever not end in
death Oh since when do you care about
the rules all of a sudden I know it's
Christmas Eve crane said it was
Christmas Eve but the bank is still open
and the kids are still in school the
school needs to seriously consider
checking its air-conditioning ducts what
the hell are these kids breathing in
addition to asbestos also the gremlin
went through the air-conditioning duct
that leads to a cabinet firm ones have
the ability to shrink at a moment's
notice these gremlins are actually
insanely good at darts for the first try
they close down all the 20s already when
did this gremlin want GT and don't tell
me saw it on video because it took
forever for that movie to be available
on video oh wow you mean one of the
Peltzer inventions finally worked
where was this asshole during the
blender sequence who keeps flea and tick
killing spray on the kitchen counter
next to the oven boggle how old is Billy
supposed to be in this movie he works at
the bank so he's clearly out of school
and I know he's into comic books and
stuff but damn toy robots Zoe its wooden
stepping in the snow get stripe wet and
make him have babies well that's not a
really dirty
wait straight blunt the door behind him
why did Billy take gizmo with him he
could have been turning on bright lights
everywhere and killed stripe with the
flip of a switch
why didn't strike do this in the first
place did he
break into the YMCA so that he could
hide in a breaker box right violates the
clear no smoking rule was posted by the
YMCA this guy who hates foreign products
sure does own a lot of foreign products
they're just going la la la I mean if
you're smart enough to take your
imitation of carolers to the level of
hats and earmuffs and sheet music why
not sing a real Carol while you're at it
just based on the time alone that she's
spiraling upward this woman must have
three or four stories worth of staircase
in the middle of her house but then nope
only one story of stairs don't do it kid
don't do it oh man you got lucky and it
didn't even knock the power up I don't
believe it either but guaranteed it
won't start when you're in danger dude
this car has been sitting here for a
long time out in the cold with snow
sitting on it for days yet the lightly
frozen windshield wipers easily knock
off the snow that should have formed
into a nice blanket how do you know rock
and Ricky these gremlins seem to know
and enjoy everything as soon as they're
born I don't know how long these guys
have been at this bar but why the is she
still serving them why did she even
start serving tiny green demon monsters
in the first place oh no she also dude
why didn't you just leave the car
running he was dressed in a Santa Claus
suit
he'd been climbing to have a chimney
holy your dad actually trying to go down
the chimney I don't think what's the
opening to this thing and Christmas
didn't kill your father Kate stupid dick
he slipped and broke his neck if he
slipped and broke his neck why didn't he
fall to the bottom I mean this chimney
is apparently big enough for a grown man
in a Santa suit with a whole bunch of
Christmas gifts there was no Santa Claus
you were nine years old you still
believed in Santa damn Randall if Barney
out the car in the freezing cold
why is Barney even along on this trip
anyway wasn't Randall just in an
inventor's convention well that was a
horrifying story about your dead dad
Kate I'm sure that will affect us all
for the rest of the movie or well just
completely forget about it let's just do
that
wait did Spielberg not want to make some
cheeky reference to his other movies in
the marquee this time how about you Joe
Dante no piranhas or howling and since
when is snow white a Christmas movie
anyway
so yeah let's go inside and take a look
I mean what's the worst that could
happen
I'm sorry to think this might be a
comedy I may be taking this movie way
too seriously
these gremlins are actually better than
most projectionists I've worked with
smart enough to throw out a movie
projector but dumb enough to start with
real for how the hell does this random
bartender girl just happen to know
exactly where the movie theaters boiler
room access door is whatever that was he
just wrenched he tightened it not
loosened oh how does that keep the door
closed man good thing nearly all of them
were in that one place at one time yeah
they're usually next to doors or
entrances of some sort also about time
now she has two reasons to hate
Christmas forever what well so how did
this TV turn on by itself I mean if
there's a switch shouldn't all of them
turn on at once and not just this one
how long does it take for a chainsaw to
cut through a baseball bat too long wait
that thing doesn't have a gas pedal
doesn't that what temperature to
mobilize have a fever I'll bet he'd like
some chicken soup what an asshole
don't have some day you may be ready
what tells mr. wing that someone is
ready for the responsibility of a mug
wine do you have to go to school show a
certificate of some sort well that's the
story so Randall has apparently been
telling the story the whole time but how
does he know about the cops who crashed
and misses deagles death and all that
other stuff he wasn't around for
[Music]
gremlins you got you gotta watch
shopping or foreigners because they
plant gremlins in their machinery that's
the same gremlins brought down our
planes in the big one maybe we should
have a little more wine is enough me oh
come on don't worry about too much wine
I mean I'm looking let you have too much
fun because you know you you know your
folks may smell it on your breath honey
might get deep into the face of the Jew
who is going to do it
[Music]